حياكم الله رئيس حزب الاسرائيلي بيتنا
الاسرائيليه
حزب الليكود
ظهر بعد غياب ودعا للاطاحه بزعيمه رئيس
الوزراء بنياميناهو تشكيل حكومه ائتلاف
جديد لبرمان قال في تصريحات نقلها لا يعلم
الاسرائيلي لا يوجد ديكتاتور قادر على
الوقوف في وجه احتجاج واسع وعادل يشمل
جميع شرائح المجتمع على حد تعبيره بالفعل
فمن يوصف بالديكتاتور
يواجه ويواجه غاضبون بعشرات الالاف في
اسرائيل ومن كافه شرائح المجتمع فيما تقول
تقارير اعلاميه ان لرئيس الحكومه ربما
يبحث عن نقطه قوه ليعاود الدوران ويملا
ويملي الشروطه على خصومه فيما تحضر تقارير
اخرى من امكانيه ان تتحول المواجهات
الحاليه الى مشهد دام بين المحتجين وبين
انصار اليمين فيما يتوقع البعض ان تضغط
واشنطن على كافه الاطراف السياسيه في
المشهد الاسرائيلي للتوصل الى تسويه او
صيغه وسط ترضي الجميع
طيب ارحب مره اخرى بضيوفي من تل ابيبا
دبلوماسيه السابق اسحاق ليبانون واسحاق
لبنان ومن تل ابيضا روبين باركو الامنيه
السابق والمحاضر ومن الناصره عبر زوم
وديعه وعوده الكاتب السياسي كنت توقفت معك
سيد وديع وتقول ان كل ذلك يستبعد العرب
الفلسطينيين او الاسرائيليين لكن نتنياهو
في خطابه قلب ليس هناك مواطنون من الدرجه
الثانيه
لا هناك ما قلت ان يعني هناك في كلا
المعسكرين الاسرائيليين المتصارعين او
المتناحرين الان نوع من تجاهل مشاريع
قوانين تستهدف الفلسطينيين على طرفي الخط
الاخضر اخرها هو الغاء قانون فك الارتباط
وسماح السماح للمستوطنين بالعوده الى
اربعه مستوطنات في شمال الضفه الغربيه
كانت قد فككت في العام 2005 الان الان هذا
يشير الى ان الديمقراطيه يعني تهتم
بالاساس في الموضوع الشان الاسرائيلي
الداخلي وينبغي التاكيد على ضروره
الاهتمام على الاقل بالاقليه العربيه
الفلسطينيه في الداخل وهي جزء من المواطن
الاسرائيليه
حينما تحدث عنه لن تكون مواطنه درجه ثانيه
وكان عمليا يتكاتب مع مزاعم وادعاء في
اليمين التي قالت مما معناه انه هذا
التوافق او هذا الراي الذي خرج به نتنياهو
عمليا ينحاز به الى المتظاهرين والمحتجين
وكان من صوت للحكومه ولليمين هم من الدرجه
الثانيه ففي هذا الخطاب واضح حاول ان يكون
نتنياهو وطنيا اسرائيليا جامعا يحاول ان
يسترد كل الاطراف وبالتاكيد جمهور الهدف
اليميني جمهور القاعده الخاصه به مخاطبا
اياه بالقول انكم لن تكونوا من الدرجه
الثانيه طيب سيد باركو روفين باركو الامني
سابق والمحاضر من تل ابيب الان هناك رفض
لخطاب نتنياهو طيب نذهب قبل ذلك الى بيلي
جانت
نستمع لما يقول وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
سابق
بعون الله
مصلحه الشعب امام كل شيء
سنجتاز هذا التحدي وسنخرج منه اقوياء
هذه مسؤوليتنا
بينما دوري ان اجاوب فاقول لك بجمله واحده
قصيره
المجتمع العربي مثل جيدا في الحكومه
السابقه تصور انت والمشاهدين انه حركه
تنتمي للاخواننا المسلمين كانت شكل
من الحكومه السابقه كفىكم من هذه المشاعر
من الخطاب والى اخره كل اوصاف في غير
محالها ليس هناك خطوره على الاقليه العرب
في داخل اسرائيل يعني خلاص
اني اذهب الى السيد عواوده ليرد عليك
انهارت انا اقول بكلمه واحده لماذا انهارت
حكومه نفتالي بنت السابقه سؤالك بخصوص
لماذا انهارت حكومه بنجانس في الحكومه
السابقه
ارجوك هذا دوري ولا لا تريد ان انا والله
سالتك يا دكتور وانت رحت الى الرد على
السيد عواوده
وانت لا ترد عليها ده غير صحيح غير وارد
لا لا صحيح او غير صحيح هذا انا تقديري
وليس تقديرك سيد دكتور انا هنا في
جاوب على اسئله ولن لا يمكن ان اتجاهل من
اقوال غير صحيحه اللي التي تستهدف الى
يعني اهداف غريبه جدا ليس لها علاقه في
هذا دورك بانه ترد علي وليس دوري
تريد جوابي بخصوص ما سميته الانكسام انا
مستعد اجاوبك
او سؤالي كان اليوم المحتجون رفضوا خطاب
نتنياهو الى اين ستتجه الامور
سابك هذا
كما قلته صادق
نحن نريد او نحتاج الى مزيد من الوقت
فنحكم ما هو رد التفعل من الجماهير طبعا
هؤلاء الذين يقفون وراء الجماهير لا
يريدون ان يشمعوا شيء الا ازاله
واسقاط حكومته ولكن الجماهير
ولسه ما سمعنا من الطرف الجناح اليميني من
جماهير الاسرائيليه وهي ملايين من الناس
عددها اكثر بكثير من عدم المتظاهرين كل
صلاتنا اليوم هي ان لا يصطدم هؤلاء
ينتمون الى اليمين مع هؤلاء الذين
يتظاهرون في الشوارع لان كل انسان له رايه
ونفتخر بما وصفه
وهو يعني
الان اسالك انه المحتاجين قاده الاحتجاجات
يرفضون خطاب نتنياهو
اذا اذا تكرمت تسمعني حتى اقدر اني انا
ادير هذه الحلقه
املاءاتك غير انا انا ديمقراطي ولكن عندي
وقت
انت تريد ان اسمع شيء لا اتوافق معه كيف
لا تتوافق هذا هذا حدث اخباري طلعني من
تعبير الراي هو الصحيح يقول يا دكتور يا
دكتور انت طلبت كلمه دكتور وتعبت عليها
خمس سنين والانصات جزء من من رسالتك
المفطرات صح يا سيدي الفاضل
طيب يعني
اذهب الى السيد ليبانون لاتحدث معه سيد
اسحاق لبنود دبلوماسي السابق اليوم قضت
الاحتجاجات رفضوا خطاب نتنياهو وهو ما رفض
ايضا السيد باركو التعليق عليه ماذا سيحدث
لاحقا الى اين يمكن ان يصل المشهد
يا اخي انتم خليتونا خارج المناقشه ما هذا
هذا اللي انا قاعد نتكلم يا سيد اسحاق
يعني اليوم الاحتجاجات هو هذا موضوعنا
لدي اغانيكم في كل المواضيع ولكن خليني
اجاوب على سؤالك لاين الاتجاه انا حسب
رايك انه الاتجاه وبعد
ما الان الاتجاه هو اخذ السياره
والسفر الى عاصمه
الدوله
طاقمين من كل طرفين وبدء المحادثات لكي
نصل الى حيلوله الوقت صغير جدا ما
فيش بما انه نحن نتحدث يعني على شهر
ونصف وهذا مش كافي
لكل المواضيع لذلك
ان الاتجاه سيكون
وهذا بين يمين يتجاهه سيجمد او يرجع
التعديلات
اوتوماتيكيا لحنا نصل الى بيت الرئيس
الدوله للمحادثات هذا ما انا اتوقعه طيب
هذا توقعك ولكن على اي ارضيه من الممكن ان
يجتمع
او المتحاورون خلينا نسميهم لاحقا
احنا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار انه نتحدث فقط
بخصوص التعديلات القضائيه وليس شيء اخر
هنالك بالاجماع داخل اسرائيل انه المفروض
انه يكون هناك تحسينات تعديلات تغييرات
مستوره يعني بهذه المعنى ولكن تعديلات اي
نعم في هذا المجال لكي نصل الى
نوع من التسويه بين جميع الاطراف وانا اظن
انه باستطاعه الاطراف ان تصل الى ذلك اذا
جلست وتحدث
ت
مع القول المفتوح لكي نصل الى ذلك لانه
التغييرات هي مفروضه ولكن مش سوى يعني كما
يتحدثون عليها ولكن هنا وهنالك في القضاء
علينا ان نحصل وتحسين الوضع لكي الفرد
داخل اسرائيل يشعر بالاطمئنان يشعر انه
هنالك مؤسسه تسانده او تدعمه او تحقق
حقوقه والى اخره هذا باستطاعتنا ان نصل
الى ذلك طيب لاذهب الى ضيفي من الناصره
عبر زوم وديع عواوده الكاتب السياسي دون
ان ندخل في في بعض القضايا الجانبيه اليوم
الى اين تتجه البوصله في اسرائيل هناك
فتره للحوار ولكن ما هي الارضيه المشتركه
بينهم
رئيس المساد السابق تمير باردو قبل قليل
كان قد خرج في تصريح للقناه العبريه
الاثنى عشر
وقال انه على نتنياهو ان يقدم استقالته
فورا نتنياهو الذي كان قائد المركبه فقد
البوصله واغرق البوصله في البحر بل اغرق
ضميره معها لم يعد صاحب اهليه لقياده
الحكومه الاسرائيليه هذا ليس نتنياه الذي
نعرفه ولذلك هذا يرتبط ايضا
بما سبق وقلت واكدت وهذا ما قرات قبل قليل
قياده المظاهرات والاحتجاجات رفضت هذا
الاقتراح الذي جاء من نتنياهو يبدو الى حد
بعيد ملغوم وكانه مشروط وكاله طالما انه
لم يتم تعنيك هذه التشريعات
يعني التحفظ عليها بالكامل لن نبرح
الشوارع وسنبقى في الشوارع حتى جانس رئيس
الحكومه الاسبق ووزير الامن السابق بني
جنس
سنحتكم الى رئيس الدوله وسنرى ماذا كان
هناك فعلا
نيه للحوار والاستعداد لسماع الطرف الاخر
نتنياهو في اسرائيل لم يعد الكثيرون يصدق
ما يقوله ولذلك ليس من المستبعد ان تبقى
الاحوال تتراوح لكن صاحب الاغلبيه رغم انك
تقول لنا لم يعد الكثير يصدق قناه نياهو
ولكنه صاحب الاغلبيه في الكنيسه صاحب
الاغلبيه صحيح وهو فاز في الانتخابات هذا
كله صحيح لكن الراي العام في لاسرائيل
الذي يخرج الى الشوارع الان ينتمي الى
اليمين وينتمي الى اليسار يعني اكثر من
موضوع
الحزب المطروح هناك يعني رغبه لدى هذه
الحكومه بتطبيق ما لم تكن وتصرح به قبيل
الانتخابات هذا تغيير عميق في النظام
القضائي والسياسي وليس مجرد اصلاحات
قضائيه تعدل من مكانه المحكمه العليا
دكتور روفين باركو اليوم هذه التعديلات
وهي تعديلات كما اشاره ضايفين من الناصره
ليست تعديلات سهله
نتنياهو هل يحظى بهذه الثقه هل من الممكن
خلال هذه الفتره فتره الاعياد وبالتالي من
الممكن ان يغير راي البقيه مثمن الذي
سيدفعه
في هذه الحاله انصح وانت تعرف رسالة
الدكتوراه تبعيه المنهج الحركي يصير
النبويه وهناك مصطلح اسمه شعره معاويه
وانا اقول انه نتنياهو وتقم مساعدين ومن
يقف جنبه يقولون له انه يعني
الاصلاحات ضروريه وهي مطلب مشترك بالكل
فئاته طيارات وكل ما هو مجتمع اسرائيلي
يشعر بضروره الاصلاحات التشريعيه القضائيه
ولكن المساله والسؤال الوحيد شو مداها شو
يعني الى اين تستهدف هذه الاصلاحات لكن
عندما نسمع يعني مسؤول امني هنا او هناك
اؤكد انه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
الانتخابات يمثل فيها الصيدا مصعوده من
بلده وزنها
الديمقراطيه ازاي وزير رئيس المصطاد
السابق ليس له اي افضليه على السيده
مسعوده من هذا هو سر الديمقراطيه في
اسرائيل والحد العام لم يتغير
وزن المؤيدين التنياهو يعني وهو الاغلبيه
الساحقه في اسرائيل وعلينا ان نستوعب ذلك
بس هل عند الثقه هل هل مازال الطرف الاخر
لديه الثقه ليمنحه او ليمرر هذه الاصلاحات
حتى ما اذا نتنياهو طرحها على طاوله
الحوار
السؤال هو ما هو الطرف الاخر
سرق من قال صدق من قال قبلي انه حتى
المتظاهرين يشمروا في من بينهم بين صفوف
المتظاهرين رجالات ولذلك
طاقه اليوم سوف ياخذ هذا بان الاعتبار
اولى في هذا الموضوع
تجميد الموضوع وتاجيله من الى بعض الاعياد
الصحيح انه العنصر الفعال الذي لا يستهدف
مساله الاصلاحات وتغييرها او تخفيف او او
يعني اي تغيير فيها هم الذين يريدون اسقاط
الحكومه
وهذا هذه تحديات اخرى هذه طيب لازم ياخذ
مساله في الاعتبار طيب اسحاق يعني
اليوم حينما نتحدث بانه الفتره القادمه قد
يسعى الشارع الى اسقاط نتنياهو لكن هل
بامكانه المضي قدما خاصه انه ان نتنياهو
بقاله بان الحوار هو حتى يبعد شبح الحرب
الاهليه وكذلك هذه الازمه التي تهدد وحده
اسرائيل
دعني اتحدث عندما انت يعني تفضلت وقلت انه
رفضوا خطاب رئيس الوزراء
الليله على سبيل المثال اللي استدغوت هي
اقوى مؤسسه اجتماعيه في اسرائيل وهي اعلى
وبعد خطاب نتنياه
و رئيس
الغابتاتا هذا الاضراب العام هذا يعني اول
نتيجه على خطابه الرئيس الوزراء بجنين
انا لا اقول انه ليس هنالك مختلفه او خوف
من طرف واحد او الى طرف ثاني ولكن نحن شعب
اسرائيل لدينا
القوه الداخليه
ولدينا ايضا
يعني نوع من
الاكسبيرينس يعني في العالم
ولدينا القوه المجلس معا ونتحاور لكي نصل
الى حل نحن نتحدث في هذه المرحله كما ذكرت
قبلا فقط بخصوص التعديلات القضائيه
وبالاخص ماذا يكون النوعيه او طريق او
ننتخب القضاه داخل اسرائيل هذا شيء يعني
باستطاعه ونصل الى التفاهم وهذا هو الهدف
في هذا الشهرين اذا وصلنا الى حل مقبول
الطرفين سيكون مفتوح لكي نحل مشاكل اضافيه
شكرا
للدبلوماسيه سابق اسحاق ليبانون وكذلك
الدكتور روبين باركو الامنيه السابق
والمحاضر ومن الناصره عبر زوم وديع عواوده
الكاتب السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك